we have a voicemail number and this is a
very interesting question that came in
today take a listen to this hi David
given that you're in the public
spotlight and you do a lot of critical
commentary of public figures whether
we're talking about you know politicians
or authors or speakers or whatever it
may be
do you ever have people to try to sue
you where they're like oh you're
slandering me you know what you're
publishing here is libelous do you ever
have people to try to silence you in
that way and if so how do you deal with
it the answer is yes and the details
I've been advised by counsel not to
discuss yet
so I've alluded to this before that
there is a big story about this type of
thing that I want to tell and my lawyer
has said he would not tell it yet and
it's I don't even want to say the
specific circumstances precipitating
that but yes that type of thing has
happened I have a story that would
shocked and appalled a lot of people in
the audience and I hope to be able to
tell it someday soon you'll know when I
do believe me on the bonus show today
Pat producer Pat had a fiasco at 4:00
a.m. last night okay I'm going to tell
you about it on the bonus show we will
also talk about ways different people
are dealing with the coronavirus
isolation Infowars has finally been
kicked off what maybe was its last
platform and we will also talk about the
erosion of deep literacy all of this and
more on today's bonus show join me there
by becoming a member at join pakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show